hello carrying on
from the question i was asked about
philosophy
it's almost really a impossible
task but i'll do my best to answer it
so
you may think that just doing taina
hainko
or striking somebody at a chamonix
100 committed
seems a strange way to talk about
philosophy
but cytosensi often said that
the students including him didn't
understand
oh sensei they tried to
but his mind was like a butterfly would
hop from one thing to another
so he had to watch him and he had to
watch him closely
and over a period of years a sense he
would repeat the
the same techniques
so he wanted to preserve those
and give the world a sense his technical
knowledge
he said once on a seminar
i just teach those senses technical
the basics of course he taught kina
nagari
flowing i've watched him do beautiful
smooth movements
i would say there were more economical
movements
but the fluidity of his body was
beautiful to watch
he he said if you want to study
other things apart from a
technical aikido that i sense he
handed down to him and this is what he
taught in the iwama dojo
if you want to know about spiritual
things
then you must find it your own direction
you must go and search out your own
guru i know for the fact that cytosinsi
had his uh spiritual person that he went
to
because i asked him once to come to
cambridge to teach a seminar
i can't remember i think i was in
america at the time and i said sensei
would you come to england in
june and he said oh i'll get back to you
i actually found out that he went back
and
spoke to his his person that he followed
to find out if it was a good place for
him to be in the world
was it in the uk a good place
for that time of the year for him to be
so many not many people may know this
but
he must have been very superstitious
he later told me that june was a good
time so he could come
and he also mentioned when a good time
was for him to go to australia
and that was obviously the other side of
the world
so he didn't teach us any of this well
not me and yeah
i never saw a glimpse of it but he was
very clever person you know a simple man
in his background working on the railway
and when i first met him he was a very
simple down-to-earth person
but what he done was he constructed
a system and he taught it to us
in hopes that we could build a strong
aikido and from a strong aikido
technical base we would find
our own philosophy we would find our own
path i
think personally i've found that
and i will be talking more about stages
of enlightenment
and what i consider important
to enhance aikido as well as the
technical side
he was a very clever man because he knew
how to teach
the western world and how to teach
the audience the orient
you see in iwana he didn't really
say a lot at all because it appears that
the way
he was taught and the japanese people
were taught
in those days was he would show
and they would copy they don't ask
questions and they just copy and they
find aikido that way
and one time when i was in iwama a
japanese student
who i felt was very arrogant at the time
said to me
you'll never understand like you know
because you're a westerner
you have to be japanese to understand
aikido
i totally disagree then and i disagree
now
the western mind we need to ask
questions
and cytosins he knew this and that's why
i think he was one of the best
if not the greatest masters that we've
seen so far
of course you'll be thinking oh of
course he'll say that
it was his teacher but i'm not saying it
because of that because you'll find in
other films i'll be criticizing him
heavily
as a person and what i think he done to
her since his aikido
in other films i will be talking about
that
but when he went out into the world and
spoke to
us westerners
he explained everything
he asked people to ask questions
because the western mind wants to know
why would you do that
what if i do this and he understood that
and a lot of the japanese masters that
i've seen
and trained with on the mat as well as
in
teaching the seminars
they would learn by showing
and the western mind often felt empty
because they would show several times
we would then get up and like a herd of
cattle charging
we would just do what we thought we'd
been shown
for the next 10 minutes
i come away from the seminars feeling
that i had a great time
really felt fitter happy with all the
training and all the people i trained
with
and then thinking back on it years later
i learned nothing
only how to have a good time how to
buzz away in my energy
and feeling great okay so
until the next film
to me the question about did cytosensei
teach post-senses philosophy
the answer is yes but in a very simple
way
he taught us tanhenko and marotti dory
if you achieve them too successfully
and i don't just mean by moving or
throwing people down
but when you can move as if the person
knew
i was one and you do not feel their grip
you do not feel their weight you do not
feel any blockages
you feel as free as you're floating on
air
then you will understand her senses
philosophy in my opinion thank you